It's Saturday morning and I'm at the boxing club at the social.
One and two. And three, and four. And hit, and bang.
On the other side of the room, there's a ballet class.
I try it.
Debbie laughs at me.
Your leg's moving!
I think about Fred Astaire.
I want to dance like him.
I run and jump down the road.
"I don't know the moves, Miss.", I said.
Follow the girls.
Go to the back and watch them.
Billy, I'm thinking about the Royal Ballet School.
There's an audition in Newcastle in two weeks.
What?! Ballet?!
My brother does not do ballet, you stupid woman!
I walked over to him.
And then, I did my audition dance.
I jumped and spun.
I wanted to show dad everything.
How do you feel when you dance?
I forget the world...
...and the strike, and everything.
There's fire in my body.
It's like...
...it's like flying.